for some of us june means summertime
pools beaches and firing up the grill
however sometimes it can also mean
blasting your ac and firing up your
favorite console or pc here are the
biggest games releasing in june 2022
mario's main source of income may come
from working with his hands and fixing
toilets but he's also pretty talented
with his feet mario strikers is not your
typical soccer game it features an
energetic mix of special moves obstacles
and team play that you won't see in fifa
the game features 10 playable characters
each with their own customization
options through stat boosting equipment
these boosted stats include speed for
dribbling the ball strength for tackling
and shooting power when it comes to
multiplayer mario strikers will offer
both online and local multiplayer at
launch up to 8 players can join a game
locally so long as each player has their
own joy-con controller online matches
include 1v1 and 2v2 options with two
local players able to jump online
together finally the strikers club
online mode lets up to 20 players join a
club together and raise through the
ranks by playing online matches mario
striker's battle league is kicking its
way onto switch on june 10th
the pori tells a story of the final day
of summer camp where a group of teenage
counselors are hosting a party
unfortunately that party isn't going to
end very well for them like until dawn
players will make choices to determine
what happens to each of the nine camp
counselors all of which are not safe
from the hands of the grim reaper the
quarry features an all-star cast
including david arquette arielle winter
brenda song and justice smith just to
name a few and if you're a little bit of
a scaredy cat like me or you just want
to enjoy the terror with a friend
because you enjoy that for some reason
then you'll be glad to know that the
quarry features online play
unfortunately multiplayer has been
delayed until july 8th but when it does
launch those who are invited to a
session can watch the action play out
and cast their votes on certain
decisions this will be perfect for when
i need to close my eyes or take a
never-ending trip to the bathroom in the
middle of playing so get ready to make
some tough choices when the quarry drops
on june 10th for playstation 4 5 xbox
one series x and s and pc
did the second sonic movie put you in
the mood to play through a bunch of his
games well sonic origins compiles sonic
the hedgehog sonic 2 sonic 3 and
knuckles and sonic cd each of which have
been remastered however player choice is
important so sega is giving you two
modes to choose from classic and
anniversary classic will be the sonic
games in the original aspect ratio with
the same difficulty you may remember
while anniversary converts to full
screen mode and offers infinite lives
you'll also be able to unlock medallions
by completing special missions which can
be used to unlock vault content and play
special stages you can relive sonic's
past again when sonic origins comes to
every console and pc on june 23rd
unlike the traditional fire emblem games
three hopes ditches the tactical
turn-based action for more dynamic
warfare taking a page out of the muso
playbook of the dynasty warrior series
however 3 hopes does have some
similarities to its predecessor three
houses as you'll be able to experience
one of three diverging story paths
depending on which faction you've chosen
to play as fire emblem warriors three
hopes launches on nintendo switch on
june 24th
announced back in 2018 diablo immortal
is the first mobile-based mmo in the
diablo series a fact which admittedly
both shocked and even frustrated fans
diablo immortal is a unique story in
diablo lore set between diablo 2 and 3
players will build characters and fight
against hellish hordes commanded by
scarn the lord of damnation the game
will launch with eight different zones
each with their own style loot and
enemies with more zones coming in the
future players can also join up in
random live events to take on larger
enemies as well as the helicory an
eight-player mission that serves as the
game's first raid experience mobile
players can experience diablo immortal
on june 2nd but that day also marks the
beginning of an open beta test for the
newly revealed pc version of the game
which will support full cross
progression with ios and android the pc
version will support wasd movement for
the first time in diablo history while
all progress made by pc beta testers
will carry over to the full version of
the game upon release
get ready to become an off-road legend
in mx vs atv legends you'll experience
the risk and reward of becoming a
professional writer in the game's new
career mode you'll take on invitational
events sign with sponsors and make
choices that can lead you down a new
mostly dirt covered path the game
features new large open environments to
explore as well as a new trials mode
that challenges you to ride in new ways
take on your friends in the classic two
player split screen way or invite the
whole squad for a 16 player online match
mx vs atv legends is racing onto pc and
every console except switch on june 28th
world slayer is the first expansion for
2021's outriders the story picks up
almost exactly where the base game left
off and even lets you pretend you've
done all the end game activities by
boosting your character up to the base
game's level cap in our preview for the
game phil hornshaw wrote quote world
slayer doesn't drastically alter
outrider's moment-to-moment gameplay so
these levels will feel similar to what
players saw in the base game although
you should expect a host of new enemy
types and bosses to freshen up the
combat along the way so grab your
friends and get ready to start looting
and shooting again when world slayer
releases on june 30th
monster hunter ryze's massive sun break
expansion contains a whole new story for
players to explore following directly on
the events of the main game this story
has hunters facing off against three
powerful new creatures known as the
three lords and in order to combat these
new threats sunbreak will introduce a
brand new ability called switch skill
swap this ability enables hunters to
assign switch skills to two different
loadouts which can be changed on the fly
during hunt players who find themselves
under attack while performing the
ability can also perform a swap evade in
any direction to avoid danger or simply
reposition for a continued assault
sunbreak is coming to switch and pc on
june 30th
originally slated for release in may
soldiers is a retro inspired 2d
metroidvania in witcher whisked away to
a mythical land on the fringes of the
afterlife soldiers is described as
having souls like combat very common
these days and you'll be slashing
dodging and parrying your way through
dozens of tough enemies the game's pixel
art world is packed with details and
there are secret pathways and treasures
to find all over soldiers releases on
june 2nd for every console as well as pc
terran command is set in the universe of
the starship troopers films which
started with the 1997 sci-fi action
movie in the game you'll fight over
different planetary campaigns and the
story and missions you take on will
change depending on your choices since
the arachnid enemies greatly outnumber
you you'll need to account for this in
your tactics and use the numerous
different units and abilities at your
disposal to take them out starship
troopers tearing command drops on june
16th for pc only
fall guys is making its way to xbox and
switch on june 21st for free 99 so you
have no excuse not to try it as
alessandro barbosa put it in his review
fall guys is a great example of the
battle royale genre growing outside of
its roots it's a far more approachable
take on the multiplayer format with
simple controls and a variety of
minigames giving this competitive game
show as much charm as they do tension
and with that being said if you don't
think it's fun at all i'll personally
mail you a check for zero
dollars shadow run has a long history
dating back to the original tabletop
game from 1989 that was first adapted to
the snes in 1993 2012's kickstarter
campaign revived the series for a new
generation and now you can enjoy it even
if you don't have a pc the excellent
trilogy of tactical rpgs include 2013
shadow run returns 2014 shadowrun
dragonfall and 2015 shadowrun hong kong
shadowrun returns is a cyberpunk meets
fantasy game set in 2054 after magic has
returned to the world along with elves
trolls orcs and dwarves you'll spend a
lot of time tracking down leads and
taking down enemies using a tactical
combat system that's backed by a complex
skill tree shadowrun trilogy is heading
to every console on june 21st
so as you can see june has plenty of
options to keep you from getting sand in
your ears and grill smoke in your lungs
not to mention the fact that summer
games fest is also in june so make sure
you tune in on twitch or youtube on june
9th at 11 a.m pacific 2 pm eastern for a
mix of new game premieres and new looks
at previously announced games and the
same goes for the xbox and bethesda's
the game showcase on june 12th at 10 a.m
pacific 1pm eastern let me know which of
these games you're most excited for and
make sure you're subscribed so you're
notified when our biggest games of july
comes out see you then